hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's ein rote
beete lebt er ist total beliebt in der
türkei und er schmeckt einfach zu
gegrilltem oder zu fleisch zum
mittagessen abendessen der passt einfach
immer und das beste ist total
unkompliziert und wir brauchen um fünf
zutaten und zwar benötigen wir rote
beete joghurt salz pfeffer und etwas
knoblauch wie in jedem traditionellen
gericht gibt es ganz viele verschiedene
arten der zubereitung ich zeige euch
jetzt meine persönliche art und weise
und dies auch super einfach wir nehmen
zuallererst die rote bete die habe ich
schon fein geraspelt und da könnt ihr
entweder aus dem glas nehmen so wie ich
das jetzt gemacht hat dann sind die
schon gar oder in ihm frische und die
könnt ihr auch roh raspeln das ist auch
kein problem
falls ihr das raw nicht mögt dann könnte
es auch gerne vorher in etwas öl
anbraten und jetzt gehen wir einfach die
rote beete mit den restlichen zutaten in
die schüssel und verrühren das
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon fertig ist der
leckere rote beete der total bekanntes
in der türkei und ich finde ihn auch
super lecker passt zu fleisch zu fisch
zu gemüse zu allem eigentlich und schaut
mal die farbe allein dafür dass er so
schön pink ist hat er von mir schon zehn
sterne verdient falls ihr das ganze
jetzt nachmachen möchte schreibe ich
euch die genauen mengenangaben unten in
die infobox ich werde euch demnächst
mehrere tipps zeigen oder auch generell
grillrezepte also freue ich mich wenn
ihr meinen kann kostenlos abonniert
damit ihr auch nichts mehr verpasst und
dann sage ich bis zum nächsten mal auf
die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]